la grève à la Fos-sur-Mer a été levée
selon la CGT et la direction et bien
elle était prolongée dans la raffinerie
totale de Donges alors que cette
française sur 10 désapprouve la
prolongation de cette grève selon un
sondage chez news je suis heureuse qu'il
y ait non seulement une grève dans les
raffineries pour contester cette
indécence de profit faramineux avec des
salaires qui stagnent dans un secteur
qui au fond
profite à un tout petit nombre au
détriment du grand nombre j'ai dit à
Madame born hier et à son cabinet quand
ils m'ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
réquisitionner j'ai dit vous faites une
connerie texto
un peu il y a des gens qui vous qui vous
interpellent ça m'est arrivé il y a de
deux jours j'ai un taxi qui m'a
interpellé juste à côté à côté de moi
pour savoir où c'est que j'allais donc
oui oui c'est c'est même souvent ouais
négociant il y a un problème il va quand
il y a un problème au lieu d'envoyer les
gendarmes à domicile des salariés pour
leur dire vous allez au boulot on se met
autour d'une table et on discute ça ça
pourrait apaiser la situation totale
doit augmenter ses salaires elle a
commencé à le faire cette entreprise a
aujourd'hui des bénéfices qui sont
importants total à verser des dividendes
il faut que le partage de la valeur en
France soit équitable j'appelle total à
ouvrir ces négociations de bonne foi et
j'espère qu'un accord pour être trouvé
dans les jours qui viennent ce matin la
direction de Total a fait un geste elle
proposait un bonus exceptionnel et une
augmentation de salaire de 6% l'an
prochain mais les grévistes eux
réclament 10% dès 2022
en relevant la tête
évidemment
un signe que vous envoyez au reste du
pays pour que le reste du pays pour que
les travailleurs de tout le pays
redressent aussi la tête que certains
veuillent mobiliser l'ensemble du
secteur de l'énergie dans une crise
d'empathie tous les français et tous les
foyers précisément sur la question de
l'énergie il y a là quelque chose qui
m'est mal à l'aise comme si il
s'agissait d'appuyer là où ça fait mal
pour des avantages personnels c'est la
plus grande centrale nucléaire du pays
la plus puissante d'Europe de l'Ouest
Gravelines depuis ce matin une partie de
ces salariés est en grève le temps
maintenant est compté je suis pas sûr
que on puisse comme ça différer
la rencontre ou les discussions ou les
dialogues mais ce que vient de faire
total peut être un premier geste
d'apaisement avec Gravelines quatre
autres centrales sont touchés par des
mouvements de grève celle de Tricastin
Cruas budget 4 noms le fonctionnement de
huit réacteurs et pertur
ça tombe mal le parc nucléaire français
était déjà en sous régime alors il avait
ce que c'est ça car c'est le badge de
France 2 que qu'on a fait à Emmanuel
Macron c'est comme il y a des maintenant
et vous avez vu la commenter une carte
il lui met une carte et puis comment il
a demandé à la Régie d'envoyer une carte
comme ça peut vous arriver parce que les
éléments maintenant
il est chez lui
écoutez ça je ne sais pas il faudra
demander il faut demander au
gouvernement puisque c'est lui qui
déclenche le 49-3 ça n'est pas la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
important revers pour le gouvernement la
nuit dernière à l'Assemblée nationale
les députés ont adopté en amendement
visant à taxer les super dividendes
versées par les grandes entreprises et
ça dépend surtout des débats dans
l'hémicycle qui ont lieu en ce moment
cette taxe sera de 35% sur les
dividendes qui dépassent de 20% la
moyenne de ce verset au cours des cinq
dernières années nouveau rapport
alarmant pour la biodiversité selon le
fond mondial pour la nature près de 70%
des animaux sauvages ont disparu en 50
ans la destruction des habitats naturels
en particulier pour développer
l'agriculture reste la cause principale
de cette disparition